[Applause]
happy friday everyone and boy is it
happy because we've got brian kill me
today
very lucky because he's been so busy of
late
[Music]
ah he truly has a strong following too
bad it's for the birds
but i'm so excited because it's time for
red meat friday
every friday we deliver you fresh red
meat so what a great time to be a
democrat because for democrats anybody
can grow up to be president
and i mean anybody
you can break any law you want and it
doesn't matter as long as you separate
your recyclables and use the correct
pronouns then you're good to go
first there's joe after years of hearing
about trump's taxes it turns out it's
joe who's soaking the irs
so in addition to the seven trillion in
debt he just saddled your grandkids with
turns out sleepy joe might owe 500 large
who knew that falling asleep in your
soup forgetting the names of foreign
heads of state and smelling the hair of
oval office visitors weren't all tax
deductible
a new nonpartisan report shows biden
properly avoided paying medicare taxes
before he took office which means he
could owe as much as 500 grand in back
taxes a half million dollars buys a lot
of poly grip and icy hot patches
but that kind of cash joe could order
fresh new hair plugs in the shape of a
giant ice cream cone and plant them from
that shiny liver spotted dome all the
way down to his vestigial tail
he has a tail
500 g's hell that's enough money to buy
one of his son's paintings
with a straw
i wonder what joe has to say about that
look look look come on man
i this is a lot of fuss about nothing
about paying taxes i haven't taken a
taxi in years
i'm the president of the united states
they send a driver for me but even back
in the day i took amtrak
and these days
i think the young people they use that
uber
that's one of those apps on your phone
what it is
speaking of hunter more emails have come
forth about him but this time not from
hunter's server and when i say his
server i'm not talking destiny his
favorite hooker with the glass eye and
club foot
he has some specific talents two emails
published by insider dating back to 2015
when joe was vp has hunter's business
contacts touting access to his dad his
relationships to then secretary of state
john kerry's stepson as well as his ties
to china
this as they decided whether to work
with hunter on a libya deal that would
unfreeze billions of that country's
assets
hunter had also requested a two million
dollar retainer yeah retainer and not
for his meth ruined teeth
but
the hookers in blow they aren't gonna
pay for themselves
i have years of rejected fox news
expense reports to prove it
now i think these emails are legit
because they also admit the downside of
working with hunter that he's a drunk a
drug addict kicked out of the military
for drugs and chasing low-class hookers
low-class hookers and all the other
stuff he listed on his resume under
professional accomplishments and awards
it's funny i just realized except for
the short stint in the army how much he
and kilmead have in common
[Laughter]
but what's with low class hookers that
sounds redundant
what's the difference between a low and
a high class hooker
my guess it's whether they take the
chevron card
and leave their teeth in
speaking of hookers drug addicted family
members and multi-million dollar
government scams
what's up with the clintons
last week michael sussman a partner at a
law firm representing the hillary
campaign and the dnc was indicted by a
federal grand jury on charges of making
false statements to the fbi about his
clients and their motives behind
planting the false rumor at the fbi
about that secret trump russia server
which like hillary's charm turned out to
never have existed
the indictment states that sussman
coordinated with representatives and
agents of the clinton campaign and
regarded materials that suspect gave to
the fbi and the media and according to
the new york post one of those agents
was jake sullivan the clinton foreign
policy advisor so this isn't a smoking
gun it's a freaking flamethrower
so the same people that were screaming
that trump stole the election with the
help of the russians were actually
trying to steal an election with the
help of fabricated russians
remember whatever the dems are accusing
you of they're doing it themselves it's
as certain as that law of physics in
which a large object at cnn will remain
at rest
unless that state is changed by somebody
walking in with a doughnut
now all this would be news if it were
trump or any republican for that matter
but it's the dems the coddled class of
the media i wish i knew this sooner
imagine what i could get away with if i
was a democrat i could grab co-workers
butts all day and get away with it
there's nothing kill mead or waters
could do about it
it would be their word against the king
of late night's word who do you think
who do you think wins that battle
i mean look at chris cuomo he protects a
corrupt brother and grabs people's asses
and still found time to order a novelty
q-tip
chris cuomo so stupid he grabs his old
boss's ass in front of her husband and
then writes an email saying hey i'm
sorry i grabbed your ass in front of
your husband
i paraphrased that
bottom line when trump won the dems and
the media accused him of everything they
were doing shrinks call this
transference but it's actually
corruption dems the press and our tech
giants working hand in hand to sway an
election and then they simply applied
their sins to the outsider the orange
godzilla who threatened their power and
you wonder why no one trusts the 2020
outcome and you see where the dems fight
election transparency and voter id it's
because their party is as dirty as the
toilet seat in a gas station
ask cat about that
because without the ability to cover up
their crimes they can't win and without
the help of the press they cannot
survive the press is to the dems what
sunlight is to a pot plant they are dead
without it
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
it's the biggest star of fox in france
but enough about ainsley earhart she was
on last night so we got this guy instead
co-host of fox and friends brian kilby
this kennedy will never leave you in a
car in the river
host of kennedy on fox business kennedy
could never be a nascar driver because
he stopped turning left years ago editor
chief of outspoken chadwick moore
and she's on this show as part of a work
release program fox's contributor cat
tip
so brian must feel really good to be on
a hit show
well it's been about six hours
and of course i had the radio show so
it's probably even less time than that
question is would i have been in the
monologue whether i was here or not i
feel like i've already been on the show
yeah and i've actually not contributed
to it you're welcome yes because what's
going on with this i'm your anti-pr
campaign right pretty much i'm trying to
enjoy your career show by show
nothing it's a push pull i get some
momentum and i get destroyed at 11
o'clock at night and it's every day and
i have to get up in the morning and then
i'm always minus five i just want to
know what you do in between fox and
friends and this show because
where do you go do you sleep under a
couch well i have a i we have a big
decision on uh fox we have to we get a
cabinet for additional clothing or do we
get a couch
i chose the couch you chose i i sleep in
the cabinet you sleep in the couch
fantastic yes yes so you really when
they always ask me uh you do you want
women in your cabinet and i say hell
yeah
don't you think it's a good thing that
all of hunter's problems as well are all
well known because now there's no
possibility for extortion or blackmail
and it's true it's just that he is
that's a big head fake as soon as you
start talking about hunter and craig
like hey he's got an addiction we've all
had an addiction that's not the story
the story is how it links to the dad and
they used to stop there but then
politico says wait a second i could get
a best-selling book if i write about the
bidens so this one reporter does one
book about the bidens and in there they
weave in oh by the way the emails were
real bam only a year late yeah and we've
already elected them now if things
continue to go bad and they think
camilla harris can do it watch all of a
sudden more truth come out and suddenly
realize that joe biden's the person the
new york post told us he was right and
that is corrupt scandalous and his son
is the good is actually the nicest guy
in the family well you know what i mean
i am beginning to think i'm starting to
develop a kind of a manly crush on
hunter because it's i just find every
new information exciting but that's for
that's not even a question more like a
confession
we always make fun of of biden for his
naps but what if he didn't nap because
like he's only awake for 30 minutes a
day
and and
in the places in the shambles it's in a
shambles kennedy no he he'd be uh he'd
need a crypt
so he he does need a cot yeah and that's
fine i still think it's cute that you
know little grandpa snoozlekins is the
president of the united states the most
powerful man in the world at any time
with his finger on the nuclear button
and uh you know we'd all we'd all be
annihilated so don't worry more we'll
stop him from hitting that low stakes
yeah yeah millie good lord millie um
yeah where was millie when hunter was
out uh boozing and floozing yeah why
wasn't why wasn't millie his body man
throwing himself in front of that
grenade i'm not sure i actually think
that joe biden is smarter than we give
him credit for the reason that they have
spent the last six months completely
undermining kamala harris and making her
a totally worthless political prospect
is because they knew all of this was
going to drop they knew this politico
reporter was working on the book they
knew they were going to substantiate all
of the emails and there's no propaganda
that jen saki can deliver that is going
to
turn this train around because you know
they are on the fast track to hell in
terms of the administration so maybe he
was doing that so he is the only viable
option because she is is so tarnished
she can't be president i sometimes
wonder if joe uh wakes up and thinks
this is all a dream
chadwick um is it time to impeach him
given all of this information because if
it were trump he'd be impeached under
he'd be sometimes over exactly
i mean we're only ever going to know the
very tiny tip of the iceberg of this i
mean there are people who know exactly
what's going on with the bidens and
they're all foreign actors and in russia
and china and now libya and who knows
what else i just keep thinking back to
the creepy hillary clinton moment where
the we we came we saw he died yeah about
gaddafi right who by the way was the
world's best dressed dictator that's how
i would i would say that's a low bar but
you're right yeah and here is hillary
the world's worst dressed aspiring
dictator
that's why i shouldn't like it but it
was we never knew why he had to die and
now and we'll never know now but now we
know that they're all these uh uh
democrat party donors that for some
reason have interest in these assets
that were freezed up in libya um will he
be impeached probably not should he i
mean if
republicans behave like democrats then
he would yeah we we're not we're not
into impeaching i i just i'm not even
into impeaching because i honestly don't
i i don't think there's that much
destructive
destructiveness left in joe do you think
it could get worse he's so i mean it's
been nine months it's like it's
fast-forwarded destruction
yeah i never ever say that something
can't get
worse because it can yes i've been to
the dermatologist
okay well sorry about that
um go in earlier next time um
modern keeps coming back well that's
what will happen um
look impeachment i just think we should
live you know in a country and under a
system
where the executive doesn't have so much
power that it would really matter that
much even who the president is because
it's not supposed to matter that much
who the president is george washington
didn't want to be president they should
be thinking about minimizing their power
but of course we don't do that and you
know everybody just wants to depend on
the government for everything
how do you feel about chris cuomo the
latest news anything i that email
it was putting it an email and then he
also had several misspellings
and grammar errors
about this apologizing for this very
serious thing i bet you they left out
the bottom that said sent from my iphone
but back in 2005 they they didn't have
spell check they didn't even have
computers yeah that's true he yeah yeah
he had no mechanism for cleaning i don't
even know the point yeah what's the
point of that editorial i don't know
what do you mean because she says i want
him to stay at cnn forever shelley ross
all right
i wanted to stay there forever but i
just want to tell you one time at a
party he did this
and he wore a shirt called the truth and
his son his brother had a bunch of
accusations that when i was done with
this i needed to shower but i didn't
know why well at least something got you
to shower
all right we got to move on hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else